Let's just talk about the
humoral response right now,
that deals with B lymphocytes.
So B lymphocytes or B cells--
let me do them in blue.
So let's say that that
is a B lymphocyte.
It's a subset of white blood
cells called lymphocytes.
It comes from the bone marrow
and that's where the-- well,
the B comes from bursa of
Fabricius, but we don't want
to go into detail there.
But they have all of these
proteins on their surface.
Actually, close to
10,000 of them.
I get very excited about
B cells and I'll tell
you why in a second.
It has all of these proteins
on them that look
something like this.
I'll just draw a
couple of them.
These are actually protein
complexes, you can
kind of view them.
They actually have four separate
proteins on them and
we can call these proteins
membrane bound antibodies.
And I'll talk a lot more
about antibodies.
You've probably heard
the word.
You have antibodies for such and
such flu, or such and such
virus, and we're going to talk
more about that in the future,
but antibodies are
just proteins.
They're often referred to
as immunoglobulins.
These are essentially
equivalent words.
Antibodies or immunoglobulins--
and they're
really just proteins.
Now, B cells have these on the
surface of their membranes.
These are membrane bound.
Usually when people talk about
antibodies, they're talking
about free antibodies that are
going to just be floating
around like that.
And I'm going to go into
more detail on
how those are produced.
Now what's really, really,
really, really, really
interesting about these membrane
bound antibodies and
these B cells in particular is
that a B cell has one type of
membrane bound antibody
on it .
It's going to also have
antibodies, but those
antibodies are going
to be different.
So we'll focus on where
they're different.
Let me just draw them the same
color first and then we'll
focus on where they're
different.
These are both B cells.
They both have these
antibodies on them.
The interesting thing is that
from one B cell to another B
cell, they have a variable part
on this antibody that
could take on a bunch of
different forms. So this one
might look like that and that.
So these long-- I'll go into
more detail on that.
The fixed portion, you can
imagine is green for any kind
of antibody, and then there's
a variable portion.
So maybe this guy's variable
portion is--
I'll do it in pink.
And every one of the antibodies
bound to his
membrane are going to have that
same variable portion.
This different B cell
is going to have
different variable portions.
So I'll do that in a
different color.
Maybe I'll do it in magenta.
So his variable portions are
going to be different.
Now he has 10,000 of these on
a surface and every one of
these have the same variable
portions, but they're all
different from the variable
portions on this B cell.
There's actually 10 billion
different combinations of
variable portions.
So the first question-- and I
haven't even told you what the
variable portions are good for--
is, how do that many
different combinations arise?
Obviously these proteins-- or
maybe not so obviously-- all
these proteins that are part of
most cells are produced by
the genes of that cell.
So if I draw-- this
is the nucleus.
It's got DNA inside
the nucleus.
This guy has a nucleus.
It's got DNA inside
the nucleus.
If these guys are both B cells
and they're both coming from
the same germ line, they're
coming from the same, I guess,
ancestry of cells, shouldn't
they have the same DNA?
If they do have the same DNA,
why are the proteins that
they're constructing
different?
How do they change?
And this is why I find B cells--
and you'll see this is
also true of T cells-- to be
fascinating is, in their
development, in their
hematopoiesis-- that's just
the development of these
lymphocytes.
At one stage in their
development, there's just a
lot of shuffling of the portion
of their DNA that
codes for here, for these
parts of the protein.
There's just a lot of shuffling
that occurs.
Most of when we talk about
DNA, we really want to
preserve the information, not
have a lot of shuffling.
But when these lymphocytes,
when these B cells are
maturing, at one stage of their
maturation or their
development, there's intentional
reshuffling of the
DNA that codes for this
part and this part.
And that's what leads to all
of the diversity in the
variable portions on these
membrane bound
immunoglobulins.
And we're about to find out why
there's that diversity.
So there's tons of stuff that
can infect your body.
Viruses are are mutating and
evolving and so are bacteria.
You don't know what's going
to enter your body.
So what the immune system has
done through B cells-- and
we'll also see it through T
cells-- it says, hey, let me
just make a bunch of
combinations of these things
that can essentially bind
to whatever I get to.
So let's say that there's
just some new virus
that shows up, right?
The world has never seen this
virus before this B cell,
it'll bump into this virus and
this virus won't attach.
Another B cell will bump
into this virus
and it won't attach.
And maybe several thousands of
B cells will bump into this
virus and it won't attach, but
since I have so many B cells
having so many different
combinations of these variable
portions on these receptors,
eventually one of these B
cells is going to bond.
Maybe it's this one.
He's going to bond to part of
the surface of this virus.
It could also be to part of a
surface of a new bacteria, or
part of a surface for some
foreign protein.
And part of the surface that it
binds on the bacteria-- so
maybe it binds on that part of
the bacteria-- this is called
an epitope.
So once this guy binds to some
foreign pathogen-- and
remember, the other B cells
won't-- only the particular
one that had the particular
combination, one of
the 10 to the 10th.
And actually, there aren't 10
to the 10th combinations.
During their development,
they weed out all of the
combinations that would bind to
things that are essentially
you, that there shouldn't be
an immune response to.
So we could say self-responding
combinations
weeded out.
So there actually aren't 10
to the 10th, 10 billion
combinations of these--
something smaller than that.
You have to take out all the
combinations that would have
bound to your own cells, but
there's still a super huge
number of combinations that are
very likely to bond, at
least to some part of some
pathogen of some
virus or some bacteria.
And as soon as one of these B
cells binds, it says, hey
guys, I'm the lucky guy who
happens to fit exactly this
brand new pathogen.
He becomes activated after
binding to the new pathogen.
And I'm going to go into more
detail in the future.
In order to really become
activated, you normally need
help from helper T cells,
but I don't want to
confuse you in the video.
So in this case, I'm going to
assume that activation can
only occur-- or that it just
needs to respond, it just
needs to essentially
be triggered by
binding with the pathogen.
In most cases, you
actually need the
helper T cells as well.
And we'll discuss why
that's important.
It's kind of a fail
safe mechanism
for your immune system.
But once this guy gets
activated, he's going to start
cloning himself.
He's going to say, look, I'm
the guy that can match this
virus here-- and so he's going
to start cloning himself.
He's going to start dividing
and repeating himself.
So there's just going to be
multiple versions of this guy.
So they all start to replicate
and they also differentiate--
differentiate means they start
taking particular roles.
So there's two forms
of differentiation.
So many, many, many hundreds
or thousands of these are
going to be produced.
And then some are going to
become memory cells, which are
essentially just B cells that
stick around a long time with
the perfect receptor on them,
with the perfect variable
portion of their receptor
on them.
So some will be memory cells
and they're going to be in
higher quantities than
they were originally.
So if if this guy invades our
bodies 10 years in the future,
they're going to have more of
these guys around that are
more likely to bump into them
and start and get activated
and then some of them
are going to turn
into effector cells.
And effector cells are generally
cells that actually
do something.
What the effector cells do is,
they turn into antibody-- they
turn into these effector B
cells-- or sometimes they're
called plasma cells.
They're going to turn into
antibody factories.
And the antibodies they're going
to produce are exactly
this combination, the date that
they originally had being
membrane bound.
So they're just going to start
producing these antibodies
that we talk about with the
exact-- they're going to start
spitting out these antibodies.
They're going to start spitting
out tons and tons of
these proteins that are uniquely
able to bind to the
new pathogen, this new
thing in question.
So an activated effector cell
will actually produce 2,000
antibodies a second.
So you can imagine, if you have
a lot of these, you're
going to have all of a sudden
a lot of antibodies floating
around in your body and going
into the body tissues.
And the value of that and why
this is the humoral system is,
all of a sudden, you have all
of these viruses that are
infecting your system, but now
you're producing all of these
antibodies.
The effector cells are these
factories and so these
specific antibodies will
start bonding.
So let me draw it like this.
The specific antibodies will
start bonding to these viruses
and that has a couple
of values to it.
One is, it essentially tags
them for pick up.
Now phagocytosis-- this is
called opsonization.
When you tag molecules for
pickup and you make them
easier for phagocytes to eat
them up, this is what--
antibodies are attaching and
say, hey phagocytes, this is
going to make it easier.
You should pick up these
guys in particular.
It also might make these viruses
hard to function.
I have this big thing hanging
off the side of it.
It might be harder for them to
infiltrate cells and the other
thing is, on each of these
antibodies you have two
identical heavy chains
and then two
identical light chains.
And then they have a very
specific variable portion on
each one and each of these
branches can bond to the
epitope on a virus.
So you can imagine, what happens
if this guy bonds to
one epitope and this guy
bonds to another virus?
Then all of a sudden, these
viruses are kind of glued
together and that's even
more efficient.
They're not going to be able to
do what they normally do.
They're not going to be able
to enter cell membranes and
they're perfectly tagged.
They've been opsonized so
that phagocytes can come
and eat them up.
So we'll talk more about B cells
in the future, but I
just find it fascinating that
there are that many
combinations and they have
enough combinations to really
recognize almost anything that
can exist in the fluids of our
body, but we haven't solved
all of the problems yet.
We haven't solved the problem
of what happens when things
actually infiltrate cells
or we have cancer cells?
How do we kill cells that have
clearly gone astray?